المعارك في بخموت تاخذ منحا جديدا باعلان
فاجنر سيطرتها على جنوب المدينه رغم شح
الذخيره الذي بات مشكلا يؤرق الطرفين
المقاومين الاوكران والقوات المواليه
لروسيا وفقا لتقرير صادر عن صحيفه قوه
راجنار ستسعى في المرحله المقبله الى
اعتماد استراتيجيه جديده تساعد في تحقيق
مكاسب اكبر وتجنب خسائر محتمله حيث
كشفين انه سيتم اصلاح المجموعه واعاده
هيكلتها وتصميمها بشكل يضمن تحولها الى
منظمه عسكريه موازيه من النخبه للجيولوجيه
خطوه ستضمن دورا مهما لقوات راجنار في
اوكرانيا التي ستكون مرهونه بموجه جديده
من التجنيد عبر روسيا التي ستتبع لانشاء
جيش دي مكون ايدولوجي يركز بشكل خاص على
تجنيد المقاتلين الشباب وفق مراقبين فان
هذه الخطوه يمكن ان تزيد فجوه التوتر بين
الكريملين وقائد فاجنر الذي يوصل انتقاد
موسكو التي تسعى في كل مره لابطاء المكاسب
العسكريه خصوصا في بخموت التي باتت نقطه
محوريه في القتال حيث ان قوه فاغنر اسهمت
في السيطره على حوالي 50% من المدينه بعد
معارك قويه خاضها الجيش الروسي جنبا الى
جنب مع مجندي مجموعه فاجنر للسيطره على
المنطقه